hello Magnus i'ts I am Ryan right from
the real rejects we have nothing to do
with Magnus that's we're gonna start off
today we're checking out the London has
fallen official trailer number one here
we go
Gerard Butler is the new [ __ ] John
McClane at least that's what they're
trying to turn him into let's watch this
poor choices Aaron Eckhart's haven't
died in this one I feel it I feel it
what security is unprecedented level
this isn't just a gathering of the
world's most powerful leaders it is the
most protected event on earth welcome to
London mr. president what's wrong bugs
the hell out of me
has decimated the British capital Wow
there is a bucket of London
is unaccounted for
to our friends in the West back away
number six on i-10 west well anymore
you're a president that's not going to
happen to be on your head
it's like some general dodge 45
we're going to kill him slowly and build
kostik behind ya
you know that don't take me it comes to
a college tutorial that's an order
London is just the first stop just
imagine every major city
the president Jesus
those who threaten our free
okay we'll rise up all right here we go
and a mistake
we will find it
destroyed
Mike we're getting you out
right back
Oh Marco I gotta admit for some reason
my egos up like as if I shouldn't like
it so I'll give you one of those cool
film school guys but honestly I like I
got the chills
I got the NIP chills right now a lot of
that looks pretty [ __ ] sweet man it
feels a lot more epic and much bigger
scale than Olympus has fallen did like I
really feel like they're really trying
to top themselves and this is like much
more ridiculous this is General Zod [ __ ]
versing Superman like the president is
not [ __ ] Superman I just don't see
someone going that far out of their way
to attack multiple countries just to get
one dude but then again who knows
I don't follow politics so I have no
position to speak on this action movie
the one thing that's kind of confused me
about the trailer is Gerard Butler was
the star of Olympus has fallen like it
was a very clear-cut plot White House is
being taken over to our brothers gonna
save the day and this one it looks like
they're not even really focusing on
Gerard Butler's character it could just
be the trailer it feels like this is
more of an ensemble action movie than it
is just watching Gerard Butler protect
Aaron Eckhart the whole time if I saw
the trailer for Olympus's home and I saw
the trailer for this I would gladly go
with London has fallen just because it
looks like a lot more fun it looks like
the scale the stakes are just way
[ __ ] so goddamn big that it's gonna
be a blast to watch a lot of these
explosions and [ __ ] happening you know
it's got that like intensity that you'd
expect from like a political action
thriller like this and Morgan Freeman
seems a lot more involved in this movie
than he was in the last one they're
really showing him a lot in the trailer
after everything has fallen in the world
then there's gonna be a documentary
about the collapse of the world which
will be narrated by Morgan Freeman I'm
pretty sure I read someone else make
that joke a while ago actually some of
the CGI at times that look good at times
look kind of shitty but you know it's
known pre-production so I'm sure that by
the time the actual movie comes out I'm
not sure I mean a lot of times it still
remain shitty I'm hoping that it is not
shitty look
in those moments I look shitty the first
one was inspired by die hard this one
looks like it's inspired by die hard
with a vengeance there's very much
similar plot points come on let's face
it and I like the epic music in the
trailer I mean if they're able to
include some of that epic music in that
epic tone in the actual movie that would
be sweet
I'm Gerard Butler but enough is always
to the side to my face whatever guys
that's it for today if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to Dan become
a rejecter bot and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope
Bradley's Stewart can I get a shout out
my youtube is grunt killer nine nine
nine nine and I've been with YouTube for
eight years wow that's fantastic
Bradley you kind of look like if Harry
Potter and Draco Malfoy I [ __ ] and had
a kiss that's what you look like tell me
you don't see that you see it you see it